- [Narrator] Located in
central London is a public park
that remains hidden to even the locals.
(inspiring music)
The medieval style church
of St. Dunstan in the East
was built in around 1100
and has had a long 900-year-old history.
In 1666, it was rebuilt
after being damaged
in the Great Fire of London.
Then, during World War II,
a direct hit during the London Blitz
destroyed a majority of the structure,
leaving behind only the north
and south walls and steeple.
Instead of rebuilding once again,
the city of London decided
to turn the remains
of St. Dunstan in the East
into the public garden,
which is accessible today
if you know where to look.
Tucked away from the main
road, the garden is situated
between the Tower of
London and London Bridge.
The green, ivy-covered
walls, trees and flowers
offer an enchanting escape from the city
and serve as a reminder
of London's history.